hi there Steve Kaufman here to talk
about language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe today I want to talk
about what I consider to be the most
important language skill and that is
comprehension all right now there are
language measurements of success or of
level and I've often said that your
vocabulary and primarily your passive
vocabulary is the best indicator of your
level at least of your potential level
because you need words all right but in
terms of a skill to me comprehension is
the most important and I'm going to
explain why using a number of different
examples this came to me actually while
I was watching a movie it was on TV it
was a Danish Swedish cooperative
production and people are speaking
Swedish and Danish
but they understand each other and
sometimes the Dane has to slow down a
little bit because Danish is harder for
the Swedes to understand than vice-versa
and I started thinking you know there
are a number of these kinds of
situations where people will speak two
different languages and communicate very
effectively Ukraine is a perfect example
many people there are quite bilingual
speak Russian and Ukrainian some people
don't speak Ukrainian but they
understand Ukrainian perfectly well so
it's not uncommon to see people speaking
and one person speaks Ukrainian the
other speaks Russian and they're both
communicating it's always been somewhat
strange to me for example that there are
ministers of the Ukrainian government
who never speak Ukrainian but they
understand it and there are certain
politicians who will be interviewed on
Ukrainian television and the questioner
speaks Ukrainian and the answer comes
back in Russian there's not a problem so
I think of other similar language pairs
you know like Spanish and Portuguese
when I was working on my Portuguese I
was listening to certain Portuguese
podcasts from Portugal and if they have
a span
the Spaniard just speaks Spanish and the
audience who are from Portugal will
understand him it doesn't go quite as
easily the other way but the point is
that there are situations and I would
imagine the same is true insofar as
Arabic is concerned I don't know Arabic
but I gather that at some level they
understand each other or they don't I
don't know but but if they were if for
example if I were to go to Denmark I
would have trouble understanding if I
were to focus and because we now have
Danish at link I would spend you know a
few weeks listening to content looking
up the words get myself familiar to the
sound of Danish I could go to Denmark
understand everything that was said and
speak to them as Swedish and I wouldn't
have a problem
similarly throughout Latin America if
Spanish speakers were to put a little
effort into developing the ability to
understand Portuguese again granted the
Brazilian Portuguese is easier to
understand than the Portuguese from
Portugal but very quickly they could go
to Brazil and if people in Brazil spent
a little put a little effort into
understanding Spanish then they could
communicate using two languages so at
least at that level comprehension is
enough for people to achieve
communication because the languages
themselves are so similar you could say
the same about Mandarin and Cantonese I
was at a reception the other evening and
there was a student there from China who
had been living in Vancouver and she
said all Cantonese is so difficult to
learn is more difficult than French yeah
not true at all
if a Mandarin speaker wants to be able
to understand Cantonese the vocabulary
is 95% the same it doesn't take much
effort of course in all of these
situations there is this element of the
will do you really want to understand it
a lot of Cantonese speakers who don't
speak Mandarin very well understand
Mandarin so this is just talking about
community
between these sort of similar pairs of
languages now if we are learning a
language that's not similar for example
I'm learning Greek right now and my goal
with Greek is to understand because I
can say simple things in Greek I can
have simple conversations in Greek
that's not difficult because it's a
controlled environment I talk about
things that I am familiar with that you
know I use a limited range of vocabulary
which means that the person I'm talking
to my high talkie tooter is using a
limited range of vocabulary but now I
found these wonderful podcasts on the
Parthenon and on Greek history and and
I'm having them transcribed but I I want
to get to where I can understand these
because once you achieve a high level of
comprehension then your ability to speak
can quickly come up as long as you have
the right attitude and then when I go to
Crete I will be prepared I'll have a
large vocabulary I'll have good
comprehension and even if I struggle to
speak at first I'll be able to stay in
the game comprehension which requires
vocabulary comprehension is the sort of
number one defense you can cope know
what no matter what is thrown at you you
understand you can then slowly you know
find ways to express what it is you want
to say now having said all of that and
saying that comprehension is the
fundamental skill we should work on
comprehension work on doing a lot of
listening and reading work on our
vocabulary and then there are people to
say well I understand very well but I
can't speak when I go to speak I can't
find the words of course that's true and
ultimately you have to speak a lot and
in order to speak a lot you have to be
prepared to put yourself into situations
where you have trouble speaking where
you sound foolish where you feel you
don't have enough time to say what you
want to say because there are four or
five people speaking and in this
language
you understand more or less what they're
saying and you want to say something and
then all of a sudden you think you don't
have enough time when there's pressure
on you or you think you did poorly of
course all of that is there and you have
to be willing to put yourself through
that you have to be willing to sound
less than intelligent be willing to
expose yourself to that kind of an
uncomfortable feeling however if you
don't have comprehension if you don't
understand what people are saying if you
don't have the ability through good
comprehension to enjoy books to enjoy
radio programs to enjoy movies all of
these things which are going to increase
the level of your language and things
that you can do on your own if you don't
have that comprehension level then the
your speaking level will never improve
so the fundamental skill is
comprehension how far you take that in
terms of being able to use what might
appear to some to be a passive level of
knowledge how far you take that into
your speaking is entirely a matter of
your own attitude if you are prepared to
expose yourself to that the
uncomfortable feeling of knowing that
you're struggling knowing that you're
making mistakes knowing that you haven't
got enough time to say what you want to
say knowing that there are words there
that you know that you can't find when
you need to use them all of these
uncomfortable feelings are on an are an
absolutely integral part of language
learning so that part of it you have to
decide for yourself but as a strategy
when I learn languages and that's
certainly the case right now with my
agree I am focusing on improving my
level of comprehension and it is slowly
improving just through the massive
exposure that I'm getting through my
listening and reading and of course
working on link so that's why I think
comprehension you know what I should
well I'll do the next video I will do in
a mixture of these paired languages
Spanish Portuguese Ukrainian Russian and
so forth just for the fun of it
okay bye for now
[Music]